last Ramadan we managed to raise 500 000
half a million meals for people around
the globe this year we're doing exactly
the same by raising half a million meals
for people in Afghanistan Yemen Somalia
Pakistan Syria and the list goes on
please donate whether you can may Allah
bless you guys there's a new brand on
the scene called alif they make 100
Halal raw cat food there are countless
health benefits to this new raw diet
check them out on Instagram alif dot UK
they do monthly subscription boxes and
you can get 10 discount on their two-bit
trial box with my code Ali 10 check them
out now and let your cat enjoy some nice
food I mean isn't it beautiful look at
that the garage is there we've got the
bedrooms there maybe we can even get
like a swimming pool or something like
that oh my God it's amazing Ali it is
brothers and sisters and that's what my
wife deserves and we deserve you know
what I'm saying we're gonna go inside I
want to show you guys inside but before
I go I need a mashallah please no evil
eye problems and sisters this is where
we will be spending the rest of our
lives
foreign
the money
until you visit the grapes
and no you will surely know
and Allah says again and no you are
going to surely know
brothers and sisters
this is our reality this is our home
this is where we're going to spend the
rest of our life you are going to live
longer underneath the Earth than you
ever did on top of it brothers and
sisters
the money the cars the
power
the phones the airports whatever you
name
your partner be your girlfriend or your
boyfriend or your husband or a wife when
you die you're going to be long
forgotten they're going to share a bed
with another person
that's the reality of Life brothers and
sisters I've been meaning to do this
video for the past two months and today
was doing a video about reminder of you
know graves in the Hereafter and I
thought it's the best opportunity
brothers and sisters
I want you guys please for the sake of
Allah
change before it's too late
please whatever you're indulged in
be it haram relationships whatever it is
that you're doing change it
we came here to film today and one of
the scenes required me or somebody to
come in and I said no
I'm not going to go in because it is
scary I'm scared
brothers and sisters
he used to at the graves weep we black
he never Weeps and the sahaba asked him
oh of man we talk about Hellfire
we talk about the Nara we don't see him
as touched when you come to the graves
why here
and his eyes soaking his tears on his
beard soaking
he said
this is where it all begins
if I make it out here inside there
if it begins good when I enter here the
rest that's going to follow is going to
be better
if it is
everything that's going to follow is
going to be
what brothers and sisters
the only thing that I want to tell you
guys is don't wait do you know how many
bodies are around me do you know how
many bodies around me
that are probably in there may I love
Mercy on all of them
maybe some of them are like I wish I
wish
can go back for one summer one sadaqa
one more day of fasting please
we are all going to regret even those of
us who are righteous in these you know
why because we're gonna say I wish I
could do more I wish I could do more
even if we're promised Johnny you know
my brother's sisters because our Lord is
the one who's created heaven is enough
and he deserves our worship and he
deserves for us to do more because
there's nothing that's going to benefit
us except
number one
something that you teach one sisters
that others learn and pass on number two
and ongoing indeed be it's a water well
be it a project a Masjid whatever it may
be and number three
a righteous son or daughter who will
teach brothers and sisters
that's all I have to say may Allah
protect us and make us among those who
are aware of this life and the prophet
saws is that visit the graves often
because let me tell you something when
you come here you get a reality check
you get a slap in the face
like never before
I'll leave you guys with that may Allah
bless you guys they'll accept it from us
and make us among the Sally
assalamu alaikum